depuis début juin les forces du
gouvernement libyen d'union nationale
ont remporté une série de victoires
décisives dans la région de tripoli
grâce notamment au soutien militaire de
la turquie
l egypte qui soutient les troupes rival
du maréchal haftar menace d'intervenir
si leur le sénat continue d'avancer vers
syrte une ville clé située à la
frontière officieuse entre l'est et
l'ouest du pays
les précisions d'hélène masculine
berceau de la famille kadhafi et ancien
bastion des champs libye la ville
côtière de syrte constitue un verrou
stratégique dans le conflit qui oppose
le gn à aux troupes du maréchal haftar
une cité qui se trouve à la porte des
plus importantes installations
pétrolières et qui ouvre la voie à une
conquête de l'est du pays qui possèdent
une frontière de plus de 1000 km avec
l'egypte franchir la ligne de syrte et
d'al joufra c'est pour nous la ligne
rouge
l'intervention directe de l'état
égyptien est devenu légitime au niveau
international que ce soit d'après la
charte des nations unies ou sur la base
de la seule autorité légitime élu par le
peuple libyen
l'objectif de l'intervention sera de
protéger et de sécuriser les frontières
de l'egypte à l'ouest avec son étendue
stratégique contre la menace des milices
terroristes et des mercenaires
depuis plusieurs mois le conflit libyen
connaît une implication croissante de
puissances étrangères
rallye faf tard principal opposant du
gouvernement basé à tripoli est appuyé
par les émirats arabes unis l'arabie
saoudite ou encore l'egypte tandis que
le gn a reconnu par les nations unies et
soutenue militairement par la turquie le
jeune a estimé nous nous donnons cela
que toutes les parties doivent retourner
à leur position de 2015 lorsque l'accord
politique libyen de skhirat a été signé
ce qui veut dire que les forces de la
star doivent se retirer de syrte et d'al
joufra telle est la position du gn a le
gouvernement libyen d'union nationale
actuellement en position de force
accusera l'ifa haftar de vouloir gagner
du temps et dénonce la volonté
d'ingérence du caire
le dossier libyen